this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app all the
babies use the cash app that's all
that's all the babies if you're a baby
and you don't have the cash app you're
not really a baby aria
this is the number one finance app in
the App Store and now the cash card is
more powerful than ever with cash apps
latest feature cash boost download the
cash app get your free cash card and
select your boost save money when you
swipe on stuff like coffee
Chipotle Shake Shack and more download
the free cash app for iOS or Android now
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know that's that's amazing we don't
we haven't done we haven't done 71
episodes yet so that's really cool and
we are doing this a little bit early I'm
recording this on a Sunday so this is a
day ago and also the people who have my
app can catch it live right now which is
right now now on Sunday but when I say
right now on Monday I mean yesterday
dude isn't it crazy how radio and
podcasts and TV [ __ ] happens later on
and you don't even know you don't even
know you don't even realize it I mean
well you realize it if you're watching
TV well maybe you don't realize it
you're a dumb [ __ ] if you don't know you
know you think you're a dumb [ __ ] if you
think Lauren orders happening is you're
watching Lauren order also can I ever
say Law & Order or do I always have to
say - Lauren order because it's New York
Lauren order or is it Lauren order one
time I knew somebody I can't remember
but it was like oh it was my cousin who
was my cousin when his a kid he thought
it was a blinkin instead of Abe Lincoln
it a blinken secure grown-up did it
stupid
okay now look I'm just gonna come out
and say it right now we got a sound
board
we got a [ __ ] sound board babies now
one fire set this up which means it's
definitely going to be janky and not
work that much however however
disclaimer full disclaimer sucks okay
sucks balls sucks big donkey balls but
here's why it sucks because when I play
it it only happens in my headphones and
one fire and I even get rid of they
don't even have we have headphones
they're like 40 headphones but we don't
have the connectors so they can't hear
the bits but I can so the bit but what
the [ __ ] it matter bits are good for
me so when I'm like dude it's on babies
now I can hear it dumb sad and you can
hear it one fire just goes by this sucks
but we can hear it babies because it's
episode 71 and I can feel it I could
feel the music happening and [ __ ] and
they don't know what the [ __ ] going on
guys I'm playing back in black say yeah
so we got a soundboard and look it is it
instant no is there a little bit of a
delay yes but it's all good do I have to
drag the song back on the [ __ ]
timeline to make it start over again yes
if I click the button twice a second
time does it start where it left off yes
is that bad yes now does it matter yes
but I can drag it back as long as I
don't have to do the same bit twice in a
row immediately which I always do yes so
it's very annoying yes but it's all good
do you know why dude
now they have no idea what I'm playing
but I'm playing back in black again that
did I have to drag it back yet
but it's fun dude and then anyway dude
it's finally let me just say this it's
so funny when it starts to get beautiful
everywhere like it's June and you just
go on Instagram or anywhere and you just
see all the [ __ ] with the
shorts on and the tank tops on and the
girls were getting ice cream and [ __ ] in
the daytime you know like girls icicle
it was it like it was like free ice
cream day or something the other day and
girls were just like it's free ice cream
day walking around with tank tops on in
the [ __ ] city in New York which is he
eat an ice cream like didn't even want
ice cream they just know that it's the
day so they got to do it now that's the
definition of a coda that is the
definition of a coda I can't believe
somebody made an app for us for the cult
it's on my Instagram I posted it but
there's the CUDA quiz app or whatever
and yeah there's some things that are
misspelled but still it's amazing does
he say hole WH o le when he means hol e
yes does he have the wrong you're with
the apostrophe and not an apostate yes
but did he do all the legwork and made
it am making a make an amazing app yes
now I did the app and you can find out
if you're at what percent cootie are now
like I said we're all a little bit coda
we all have that in in us and being a
CUDA is you know coming from Barracuda
you see a [ __ ] Bling bracelet and
barracudas like attack it you know I
mean if I give you a ship fishing and
then you bring the barcode on the thing
and your idiot wife has like a [ __ ]
$100,000 bracelet the code is gonna kill
him so that's what you're like when you
see a [ __ ] Oh Arby's has a new beef
[ __ ] burger with bacon and cheddar and
bubble gum on it gotta go eat CUDA now I
got took the quiz but Oh a little bit
couidn't you can't be a robot
so I took the quiz I was 5% CUDA and I
think that that's great 5% is what you
strive for 0% there's something fishy it
sounds like you're lying you know anyway
so I I wasn't gonna say she already off
track pretty cool seven minutes in soft
track and I you know what I I also I
also I also am going to New York and I
can't wait dude you know what New York
is New York is an amazing place to visit
I lived there for a year and got
depression and it's all good I don't
think it was New York I was going to
college too and [ __ ] I hated college
so much do it I hate let me go on record
and say this dude and and I it's not
good for everybody but I hate school man
I [ __ ] hated school I hated high
school college the school before high
school and the school before that
whatever those are elementary and [ __ ] I
just don't it's like it's a weird
[ __ ] thing school because it's like
it they have to make it as as general so
it does it's like you know watered-down
comedy you watered-down the comedy so
everybody's happy so you don't offend
anybody but that's what schools like you
got to have the most general [ __ ]
studies and learn math unit I mean the
[ __ ] I'm a comedian the [ __ ] do I care
about math so look for me for comida
anybody who's in the arts you don't need
to go to school dude if you're in the
[ __ ] third grade drop out drop out
the second you stop painting and [ __ ]
with your fingers and [ __ ] and you're
like it's art day yeah the second you
stop that stops drop out if you want to
be an artist I knew I wanted to be a
comedian since I came out the womb dude
I came out and I was like why did the
chicken cross the road now it's not a
podcast if I don't do a fart sound or
mention Tupac is it
but uh yeah so so so but if you want to
be a doctor obviously you got to go to
42 years of school you got to go to 42
years of school but yeah do it
anyway I was in New York living there
here's I just like why doesn't everybody
just live in a place with the weather
always good like Chicago's [ __ ]
bangin dude
Chicago is [ __ ] bangin but then you
get to Chicago in February cut my head
off you get to Chicago in December saw
my limbs off did bury me what stay
indoors but like Chicago is good for
like a month dude straight up all these
other places
Kentucky [ __ ] Virginia Connecticut
they're good for a month the other 11
months she'll live in 4d going to work
and you're cold as [ __ ] dude whatever
happened to Asher Roth with that song
College one fire is playing Asher Roth
in the background like just what
happened to him does he still rap he
does do it right
he probably has a [ __ ] he probably
owns like a chain of print shops or
something how weird is it went like a
child star or something not that he was
a child star but like when somebody
grows up like what are these [ __ ]
some of these vine guys gonna do like
what are these guys gonna do who are a
big on Instagram and then when Instagram
goes away what the [ __ ] are they gonna
do like what's uh that guy who always
made that [ __ ] that pasty white guy
that was like [ __ ] guy's name I don't
even know his name anymore he was like
31 when vine huh I'm describing me but
like he was like 31 when vine was going
on and it was like Charles or some [ __ ]
I don't remember it was [ __ ] awful
though whatever the [ __ ] it was he had
tattoos and [ __ ] what's he doing now and
then he got like in trouble for cuz some
girl said he raped her the [ __ ] that
guy's name and whatever it was it was it
was awful now what's he doing now he's
like four
now and just being a we give one's a
printshop
I don't know but anyway yes so what he
got a vine tattoo oh Jesus Christ oh
yeah that's him I won't even say his
name didn't didn't deserve
wow he's still got [ __ ] a lot of
Instagram followers Jesus Christ God
even though just the stills of the
[ __ ] Instagram videos are like
[Laughter]
Instagram videos where the [ __ ] [ __ ]
where the stuff I follow out like
Fitness people on Instagram and do you
ever see like like on the explore page
I'll get like they'll show like a
fitness guy and it's a video and or no
no it's just a picture and then it'll
like have a red circle around the
[ __ ] part they want you to see like
abs like this and then it'll have a red
circle around the ABS like we know where
the [ __ ] ABS are you don't have a red
circle around it how dumb are we so I
don't know I was at what was I gonna say
though I was gonna say something about
the [ __ ] I was at the [ __ ] coffee
mean oh no I got my car washed is what
it was and I just got my car wash in one
fire and I didn't get rid of was waiting
for me to get back because I was getting
my car washed and I was just sat there
and look here's the deal when you get
your car wash get your car washed you
get your car wash that's it that's what
you get the job you get on your car wash
is the job you got on your car wash okay
when the guy swings the towel around and
goes hey you're done you go up you give
them the [ __ ] tip you get in your car
you get the [ __ ] out of there you know
what you don't do a once-over dude you
don't look this is something if you're a
dude you do this you're a [ __ ] and if
you're a girl you do this you're a
[ __ ] diva dude when you see I
saw this woman there with a red dress on
with a red [ __ ] Sunday dress on just
pointing at spots that weren't clean and
the guy was like okay and he was just
and dude she
look if you leave a [ __ ] if you say oh
you forgot to do the tires I pay for the
tires okay but this girl was like
there's a spot there there's a spot over
there there's a spot over there dude and
the guy was just like what if I worked
at the carpet dude I would be fired
immediately there's a spot there I get
the one spot she said oh there's a spot
over there I say oh really okay I get
another spot and then the third spot she
said there's a spot over there
I'd look at her and I'd say go [ __ ]
yourself you're not gonna Beverly Hills
me baby you're not gonna Beverly Hills
me man you don't bring that you know
what keep that [ __ ] in Beverly Hills how
about that we're in [ __ ] West
Hollywood [ __ ] that you keep that
Beverly Hills [ __ ] in Beverly Hills man
it goes as far as bel-air and that's it
you bring that [ __ ] down - WeHo go [ __ ]
yourself you bring that [ __ ] down - WeHo
go [ __ ] yourself dude seriously dude get
that [ __ ] out of here man I can't
[ __ ] I told you about the time I got
Beverly Hills at the coffee bean in
Beverly Hills did I tell you that [ __ ] I
think I did that early on in this and
one of these episodes where I I was
standing in line at the coffee bean
trying to get a coffee and this Beverly
Hills [ __ ] woman who was like 60 70
years old and looked like a [ __ ] mommy
because she got so much work done she
came in and stood in front of me in line
she stood in front of me in line how
[ __ ] and I said Oh ma'am I said ma'am
that's by the way that's the sound board
but I said oh excuse me I was I was in
line and she goes and I said I um I'm
not joking she said no you were over
there and I didn't even move I didn't
even move I was standing I watched her
walk in and stand in front of me and I
said excuse me I was waiting in line and
she said no you were over there and I
said no I watched you walk in I'm right
here waiting in line and she said oh no
you weren't and then [ __ ] caught me
I mean literally that happened and now
it was in Beverly Hills so I get it but
also go [ __ ] yourself too cuz they my
head I made up a backstory about her I'm
like oh or a husband works so hard makes
money and she's just [ __ ] spending it
even though that sexist that was the
[ __ ] I went to in my mind one time I was
looking at one time one time I was
looking at I was driving and I was you
know how you get in one of those stairs
where you're just like zoned out and it
feel so good and comfy as [ __ ] to just
stare it like a leaf and you're just
hanging I'm talking about where you're
just like this you can see on the video
pod but you're just like [ __ ] glazed
over and everyone's like and everyone
and and and and you're and you're just
like I don't want want to get out of
this I hope no one bugs me and cause my
name because it feels so comfy so I can
orgasm for your eyes it's like an orgasm
behind your eyes and and I was doing
that I was Paul I was on in a Rhett on a
red light at a red light not on a red am
i a Russian spy I there's only red light
no I was in at a red light and I was
just staring at this Mercedes window and
now it was so tinted and and the windows
were up and I was just staring at this
into space at this Mercedes this really
nice Mercedes I guess I didn't know it
was really nice until afterwards but the
window rolls down like a crack which was
first of all if you're gonna roll down a
window in a car only a crack and you
didn't just get the car washed whatever
you're gonna say is going to be the most
[ __ ] [ __ ] of all time rolled down the
whole window if you roll down a little
bit and you're just like and you're just
like hey man [ __ ] you know you're
just a [ __ ] what are we gonna say I'm
not giving an example but so the it
rolls down a little bit okay
this dainty woman hand comes out with a
[ __ ] ring on it and she [ __ ]
flashes the ring at me like I was
checking her out now here's how you know
your [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] how you
didn't even pay for the car okay cuz you
don't know that the windows are tinted
you didn't go get the windows tinted and
you don't know they're tinted because if
I'm staring at a window that's tinted I
can't [ __ ] see if there's even a guy
or a girl in the car what if that was
the last [ __ ] I said and then I just
died it was a hundred percent tinted it
looked like it was paint and and I and I
was so taken aback dude
that she had the audacity to think that
I was checking her out through a tinted
[ __ ] window that my jaw drop now I
was like a young buck I was like twenty
two and I was like oh my god like what
is she doing I I actually you know when
things happen and then years later you
remember it and you're like that
couldn't have happened that's what I
[ __ ] feel like but I know it happened
so she she went like this and waved her
[ __ ] big-ass ring that obviously her
husband bought for her because you know
and and after she drove away I had the
[ __ ] best slam of all time and I
didn't do it because I was so in shock
because I was a young pup now if you do
that to a 38 year old me and you do that
then I [ __ ] immediately clap back
with a [ __ ] oh I was wondering how
you got such a nice car cuz there's no
way you didn't pay for it awful [ __ ]
sound board - it came in
it [ __ ] grew it swelled it wasn't
even I should have picked why are they
[ __ ]
[Music]
dude she showed me her ring bro you know
how much that's the biggest ego [ __ ] of
all time oh he's checking me out here's
my ring I wasn't also you're sad you cry
a lot if you do [ __ ] like that I know I
won one of my super powers is I think I
think I know how much people cry
individually I think that this is my
x-men power one time I was dating a girl
in Utah I wasn't in Utah but she was and
um this was years ago and she had a
roommate and she was like I really like
her she's great and I was like yeah
she's real sad though she cries all the
time and she was like what and dude the
whole year she would cried the whole
time she was like how did you know
because I [ __ ] know bro I know how
much people cry I know him when somebody
cries on one they don't do it I can feel
it not like in a I can feel when it's
happening but like you know unbreakable
when he walks by and touches somebody
and then he's like this guy did that I
gotta go [ __ ] this guy's did that in
a bad way I know when somebody cries
because you could tell it's written all
over their faces dude if you post a
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] on Instagram you're
like this is the world we live in and we
got to make it better and recycle and
this and that you cry you cry all the
time
my body is sexualized when I choose not
when you do you cry all the time you cry
cried you cried your cry-baby you can't
say [ __ ] like that and not cry all the
time
emotional emotional that lady who
Beverly Hills me I don't know if she
cries but I hope she does
she deserves a sob and a stay that's
what she deserves
and these [ __ ] people at the
establishments they don't give a [ __ ]
you know they're just serving coffee I
think there's like [ __ ] I was at the
coffee me you know I think that there's
like people two people came out to me
hey what's up Chris hey dude here's the
deal if you don't know me and you just
know my [ __ ] you got to come up in a
different way you can't do that
hey what's up you like the you know me
hey what's up what's up Chris hey do I
know you're not don't confuse me if
you're just saying hey cuz you know me
from TV or some the Internet you got to
say something like that oh hey how's it
goin Wow hi or oh nice - nice to see ya
oh you know even if you're like I don't
like your [ __ ] [ __ ] you you know but
like don't be that something no know me
from there and be like oh what's up
Chris oh hey I do I know you I'm so
confused when that happens one guy some
guy won't won't one time some guy come
up came up to me I forget I was that
some I was like some gig and he was like
hey man you're on that show Whitney huh
they're close I came to punching a guy
out of my [ __ ] adult life hey man
you're on Whitney huh yeah ah that's
your [ __ ] sucks but you're alright I
walked away and like what a [ __ ] what
a [ __ ] you know like what and I goes and
tells his friends oh yeah you're
romantic so we were talking about I
forget who I was talking about this with
but we're talking about who stole things
in their life I've I've stoled one thing
in my life and I know what it is and
have I told you guys this I'm not a
podcast I was at CBS or something or
pick and save or save on whatever the
[ __ ] these things are shop right I don't
know where you are in the world but
something like that and they were
selling these hats you know how like why
the [ __ ] by the way the CVS and like
pick and say or not pick and save I get
up at CVS and like save on drugstores
why the [ __ ] do they sell like
long-sleeve shirts you know like not
even just t-shirts they'll sell like a
long-sleeve shirt and like [ __ ]
like like like zebra print red and black
zebra print pants who's shopping here
like [ __ ] moms and MC Hammer like
what is it for who who buys the [ __ ]
long-sleeve shirts at a dry store huh
you go into a drug store here's what you
get dude you get drugs you get Windex
you get [ __ ] maybe tinfoil and you
get balloons at the most maybe you buy a
frisbee if you walk out of a drugstore
with a long sleeve shirt and some pants
reevaluate
it's insane gonk gonk so ice I was at
the drugstore and I had this like
Epiphany I was like they shouldn't be
selling his [ __ ] there so I'm [ __ ]
2020 and I walk in there and I see a so
I swear to God it was I can't remember
what it was it was not a CVS but
something like that
what was it dude a Rite Aid that's what
it was I don't know what it was the
saves were righted so they were selling
hats okay now it's one thing at the
drugstore this is the thing at the
drugstore you'll always see baseball
hats with different like with different
like like you'll see you know what I
don't like baseball hats for football
teams dude no absolutely not you want to
wear a baseball hat you wear either a
funky baseball hat with a crazy random
design or you get a [ __ ] baseball
team on it let me tell you what you
don't get you don't get a baseball hat
that says the bangles on it
that's a football team if you're a fan
of the bangles you get the [ __ ]
helmet bro you get the helmet you get
the helmet if you're a Bengals fan you
get the helmet and you [ __ ] get you
get shoulder pads too dude as a matter
of fact you got to get the shoulder pads
you got the you get the shoulder pads
and you get the [ __ ] in and the coaches
should be wearing that [ __ ] too there's
some comedian that does a bit about how
baseball players are the only baseball
or maybe it was my uncle that said it my
uncle Vinny was like baseball is the
only team where you where you're the
coach where dresses like the players
imagine imagine Pat Reilly with a with a
bass basketball jersey I think that's my
uncle who says it maybe this probably
could mean he has a bit like that anyway
yeah dude you get the [ __ ] helmet man
dude I was way by the way so I'm gonna
get back to the Robins story I robbed I
robbed I'm a robber so I run one story
said I'm gonna do this story first
because I started it so I got the I got
the raw I got the [ __ ] a robbed I
robbed the Hat I saw I saw I see a hat
okay
blew the story where me too but so I see
the Hat and it's it's literally got it
this was before monster energy energy
drink it was a white hat with green neon
zebra print on it it looked it looked
more like monster though like neon green
hat with white and bright clean white
neon green and I see this baseball hat
and and [ __ ] rite aid or whatever is
selling this hat like they're just
selling these hats with like green neon
[ __ ] white baseball hats and I'm like
this [ __ ] who would ever as a 20
year old I'm like who the [ __ ] would
ever buy this I was with my roommate who
come here by this and he was like yeah
that's crazy and I was like you know
what dude this hat so [ __ ] stupid
first of all anywhere okay anywhere it's
[ __ ] stupidest [ __ ]
um I'm gonna put it on my head and if I
gonna because I came for whatever I came
for probably like Gatorade in you who I
was 20 who the [ __ ] knows and they're
like a [ __ ] Snickers bar or some ice
cream probably
Oh ice cream the way ice cream dances
around your tongue dude I love ice cream
anyway so I mean just that cold [ __ ]
feeling of having a dance and [ __ ]
play around your [ __ ] mouth dude so I
got this hat so I put this out of my
head you know what if I could if I could
buy all the [ __ ] that I'm gonna buy and
you and wear this hat out while I'm
doing it I deserve it it's technically
not Robin so I put on the Hat I went to
the [ __ ] cashier bought my [ __ ]
ice cream my dancing around tongue ass
ice cream there it is there's the
[ __ ] head that's the hat vintage
zebra tiger stripes surf neon I mean how
many words is on it that's the Hat dude
they're still selling it it's 43 dollars
from what was I say kook school oh oh
the website is look school dot top hey
[Music]
that's the sound board dude hey look
school dot top ah [ __ ] Samberg wow
that's the actual hat dude from [ __ ]
20 years ago I got to get that hat dude
I'm gonna buy that hat so I put it on my
head and I paid for all my [ __ ] looked
at the cashier in her eyes I said thank
you and he said thanks a lot and I
walked out and and and I was like I
think that that's the rule if you could
walk out of it in plain sight and own it
I learned a valuable lesson that day if
you just confidently own your [ __ ] and
nobody asks you questions you know
nobody asks you a question that's why
nobody ever asks when you walk into a
[ __ ] 7-eleven and
already drinking of SmartWater and you
go by a Chipwich and then you walk out
with it nobody asked you Oh nobody asked
you to pay for the [ __ ] smart water
cuz you're confident you're not nervous
as [ __ ] if you start drinking the [ __ ]
in the store because you took it and
you're drinking it and you're nervous as
[ __ ] to say all you got to pay for that
- [ __ ] that that's my hat I put it on my
head I knew it was my hat that's how it
was it was like the sword in the stone
it was like the [ __ ] funky ass anyway
so before I tell you about this [ __ ]
story about the the football helmet let
me do my ads here me on days look you've
definitely heard me talk about me undies
I got him on right now I got my new gay
pride underwear that they sent me
that's very colorful and but they're
very these all of the patterns are very
fun and cool and there's a most comfy
underwear that you that you can buy and
there they feel as good as they look
they're just they're just awesome I love
them that's all I wear but to those of
you haven't tried them yet listen up you
can get incredible underwear sent to
your door with me undies meaning no more
hunting around for the perfect pair at a
crowded store and eventually settling
for good enough me undies are made with
sustainably sourced material from beach
wood trees they're naturally soft fiber
makes a fabric that won't sag or ride up
just trust me once you get them you
won't wear other underwear I'm telling
you okay
me undies is so sure that you'll love
your first pair that if you're not happy
they'll do whatever they can to make you
to get you into the right pair and if
they can't keep them in they'll refund
you how about that man
risk free to try the best underwear sign
me in dude sign me up so far in uh you
still not sure well me on Days has a
deal for my listeners first-time
purchasers get 20% off their first pair
of biondi's and free shipping that's 20%
off plus free shipping and a guarantee
that you and your me undies will be very
happy together get your butt over to me
undies calm and treat yourself get your
20% off your first pair free shipping a
100% satisfaction guarantee go to me on
DS comm / Congrats that's me on DS comm
/ Congrats I'm telling you babies post
pictures with your underwear when you
get them
square cache if you haven't heard we're
switching to the cash app by now you
know it's the number one ranked app in
finance and lets you do the most with
your money whether you want to pay
people back buy and sell Bitcoin deposit
your paycheck right into the app or
order a free custom cash card to spend
anywhere you like now the cash card is
more powerful than ever which with cash
apps latest feature cash boost the cash
cards boost program lets you get instant
discounts every time you swipe your card
right now you can get a dollar off every
purchase you make it coffee shops across
the country when you pay with your cash
card and you know I'm hitting them
coffee coffee shops love coffee shops so
cash cash up is amazing for me and it is
for you too so it doesn't stop there IIC
discounts like 15% off at Chipotle 15%
off Shake Shack
have you had Shake Shack it's real good
and more they're rolling out new boosts
for the cash card constantly so follow
at Cash app on Instagram and Twitter to
find out what boosts are next to get
boosted download the cash app and get
your free cash card and select your
boost and of course when you download
the cash app and enter rewards code
Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund download the free cash app for iOS
or Android now what yeah he wasn't doing
the timer so I'm on fire I did it on
here cuz I'm smart I was at I was you
last night this is what I want to talk
about the Giants hat ok my buddy had a
giant's hat on okay a not the baseball
team he had on the [ __ ] football
giant's hat on baseball hat that's weird
that's like having a [ __ ] rope well
actually they do probably do make
Rollins that's like having a [ __ ]
chipotle hockey stick okay it's just
done you have a Rangers hockey stick
you're a fan of
the [ __ ] Rangers are you a fan of the
Rangers you wear a hockey mask you walk
around town with a hockey mask you don't
get a baseball cap with the Rangers on
it okay
anyway this guy Zach donk ovo I've
talked about him on the podcast before
he's that guy that laughs at everything
dude it's unreal it's unreal he goat he
said the other day of the other day we
were hanging out and he was like oh
that's a nice hoodie he laughs at
everything and I said ah thanks bud he
said what brand is it no he said nothing
I said yeah I said ah thanks a lot dude
I've had it for like five years it's
like Ralph Lauren and he goes I get what
dude he laughed at me saying yet I've
had it for five years as Ralph Lauren
it's so we're you know he's like he's
like the guy from [ __ ] he-man the the
guy that they he man goes and sees the
old [ __ ] wizard guy and every time he
goes and he's he laughs at everything do
to piss me off i watch the first episode
of he-man the other night it pissed me
off dude it's not Orko it's not work oh
it's he talks like this and every time
he says something he goes afterwards
it's so cartoon it's so 80s you know I
can't see he was in the hall he's
definitely the first episode I don't
know if he was a [ __ ] how gay is
he-man you know dude this [ __ ] it's so
bad I was watching the toys that made us
it's just so bad and then I was watching
the first episode of he-man
it's like they'll be like oh thanks
he-man but where's Prince Adam and he's
like oh he had to leave for a little bit
right better you know I mean what the
[ __ ]
at that point wouldn't be like oh you're
a prince Adam he's not Prince Adam we
have to do a spell oh that's Zach dunk
ovo the [ __ ] wizard in he-man anyway
so uh he men's hair you know he man's
hair dude what the [ __ ] is that you
gotta send that to me I gotta watch that
he's pulling up some [ __ ]
looks like some [ __ ] he-man Skeletor
EDM dance battle or some [ __ ] anyway so
so so he laughed at that for no reason
so he laughs at everything so my so the
other issue the some context don't
really need to know this part but Zach
Tonko vo the other day oh he asked if
that Ralph Lawrence what was shirt the
hoodie he says is that diamond I said
what he said is a diamond I said oh no I
don't know what diamond is and he said
aw it's just like escape prey and I was
like ok well no it's not I don't really
wear skate brands not to knock on my
some of them are really cool but no it's
not diamond it's Ralph Lauren and he
goes so I say so now flash-forward to
like two days later he's got on a
diamond hoodie okay and then and he's
wearing a giant space ball hat it says
Giants on it alright so I say to him
look at this idiot with two wearing two
brands like all in your face
Giants and the [ __ ] diamond brand and
him and my idiot opener michael anoche
go like this the Giants isn't a brand
and I said huh and he said it's a team
hey man I know and dude and we were with
more people and everyone's like oh dude
don't be an idiot you think the Giants
is the T is a brand on what [ __ ]
planet you [ __ ]
or the is our football team's not a
brand dude my opener is so stupid and he
was like no it's not a brand and then
even Zack who is I don't think is stupid
was like are you wrong the Giants is a
team if football team just cuz it's not
a clothing brand doesn't mean it's a
girl hey is tricks is a [ __ ] brand
McDonald's is a brand dude I was [ __ ]
late yeah I was
[ __ ] you know what it was the end of
Braveheart that's what it was that was
the end of Braveheart for me I don't I
went out five people were arguing
against me it's not a brand boom boom
boom
I'm at the OK Corral boom boom boom
where's Butch Cassidy cuz I'm the
[ __ ] Sundance Kid
boom boom bap bap bap bap dying for what
the [ __ ] I believe in dude and they were
like you we you know what they literally
protectable this [ __ ] you know what we
just disagree no there's no disagree bro
you're wrong
they're brands how can you say the
Yankees aren't a brand
boom boom boom six shooters whatever's
left boom boom click click click like at
the end of Braveheart where he's like
whereas like say you're scared or
whatever [ __ ] he says worse worse
recalling up whatever and he's just like
freedom dude
you walk by the way you watch the movie
Braveheart once and that's it you don't
watch it again you don't watch it again
you don't disrespect that [ __ ] movie
and watch it again
you watch it once god damn it dude when
I was in high school the [ __ ] mother
I had these dislike the they with this
like this young life [ __ ] which was like
I was friends with a lot of guys who did
the young life young life a dog you
don't know what it is it's a brand but
it's uh it's like a Christian they sing
around and play [ __ ] guitar music and
they around a campfire and they sing
about Jesus and it's straight up [ __ ]
awful it's boring his [ __ ] and their
Braveheart was just their favorite movie
and they always wanted to watch it and
it [ __ ] grinded my [ __ ] gears do it
you watch that movie once and that's it
you know you don't watch [ __ ] movies
like that that that tear you up on the
inside more than once you watch comedies
more
once these stupid rules you watch
comedies more than once and that's it if
you watch a drama more than once you're
you know what you do you cry a lot
you're lost straight up you're lost
where are you someone [ __ ] ring ring
up your mom's looking for you in aisle
nine
your mom's looking for you you're
wandering around target that's who you
are but they love and they love it you
know what's gonna happen you watch it
you [ __ ] you know what I mean
my brother would disagree disagree with
me so much unless it was it from an art
standpoint my brother is a filmmaker
fine you that's okay
you watch he watches casino every other
day and it's but that's because that's
his job
you know but if you're just some weirdo
that watches some [ __ ] drama twice
you know what okay three times you're
gonna watch Schindler's List four or
five times what the [ __ ] is you cry a
lot dude you cry a lot about everything
about like your appearance about the
what's going on in the world about like
sometimes you cry about like animals in
the wild
you're a [ __ ] crazy get it together
dude how about that if you watch
Braveheart more than once get it
together by the way literally no clue
what I was what story I was talking
about oh yeah so Braveheart but I get to
get the Braveheart from [ __ ] did oh
yeah yeah dude that was my Braveheart
moment man I'll [ __ ] I will cut me
open dude cut me open before I before I
admit the Giants aren't a brand these 5
[ __ ] looking at me like they
like the older guys in Braveheart that
are just like man you will concede no I
will not
freedom [ __ ] freedom
I like it I don't know how I I remember
even being this way like so like
afterwards my opener was like yo you
your kid just just cuz you say it like
that doesn't mean it's true
and and which is not it's not true
because I say it like that it's true cuz
I it's true and I and and and and I've
I've learned throughout the years in my
life that if you say something
confidently just like I said you put the
[ __ ] hat on your head you walk out
confidently nobody's gonna ask you
anything
right but if you're confident that's
what you learn how to doing stand up
when you're doing when you when you say
like Bryan Callen is one of the best at
it
like he'll tell a story about how he a
bill burr is great at it you'll believe
them just because of what they're saying
and how they're saying it because
they're they believe it and they know
it's true and but but I remember be I
remember coming it's weird to think of
like I always like to think of like how
I became the way I am and like I go back
always to like how I was as a child and
how I figured stuff out and how I
learned about stuff like like the
weirdness how it grows and and turns you
into who you're going to become like
like the like when this isn't part of
the story but like when I when I when I
first went to school when I first day at
school when I when I woke up my dad's
like time to get ready for school and I
got ready really quickly and I ran
downstairs I ran downstairs and I was
waiting at the front door and my dad
said hey Chris what are you doing like
as I was just sitting at the front door
and I said and he said we got to go to
school
and I said what and I looked at him and
I said where's the yellow buff like
because I thought because in my head I
had seen like books and and TV and like
people get picked up in the school bus
you know in the yellow bus and he was
like no I'm gonna take you to school you
know what I mean
and I was like oh there's no yellow bath
and he was like nah and I went to school
in a car which I felt really weird about
and when I went and the first day of
school and then I did it and then I but
got home and then the next day I woke up
for school my dad woke me up and he said
hey Chris wake up for school
and I looked at him and I said again
like I was like you got to go to school
twice it's like that video that went
viral today the other day about that
barstool sports posted were the kids
like I thought cuz I did sit-ups my
stomach is supposed to shrink and
they're like now it takes a little
longer than I thought when you go to
school once you learn you're done but
like I remember thinking when I was a
kid
that's this is [ __ ] like I didn't
even know what the word [ __ ] was but
I in my head whatever that word was I
was like this is that whatever [ __ ]
is this is that feeling that you got to
go again and what do the same [ __ ] and I
went again and again and again and again
and every day I woke up til I was out of
[ __ ] high school I thought again
again I gotta go until I was out and
then I went to
Hut for one year and then I literally
was like what the [ __ ] am i doin dude
get me out of this jail and I did and I
[ __ ] still wake up sometimes and
think I'm so happy I don't have homework
as a 38 year old it kind of petered out
the over the past five six years but
even in my early 30s I'd wake up
thinking like no homework today [ __ ]
yeah but that's that's what I that's
what I there was something in that story
that I wanted to tell something happen
in that story that I wanted to tell I
can't remember there was a [ __ ] aw
[ __ ] thing oh yeah when I went to school
on my first day of school I was so
scared dude I was paralyzed with [ __ ]
fear I didn't know what the kids were
gonna think of me I didn't know if the
teacher was gonna [ __ ] become Eva
seriously seriously as a kid I was
scared of [ __ ] like my teachers going to
kill me I thought oh my teachers maybe a
demon she's gonna [ __ ] steal me and
abduct me I was like not scared
petrified of this [ __ ] and I my dad
dropped me off at school I was like dad
will you please wait outside the
classroom like I wanted him to come in
wait in the hallway and this and he was
like no I can and I was like dad please
and he was like he just finally was like
okay whatever he did whatever he would
say to get me in and I was like girl
would you wait there really and he said
yeah sure I'll wait right here I guess
and then I put my head in and I tricked
him and I popped it right back out I
said you're still here and he said yeah
I'm right here and then I had to go
start class and then the first break I
could like when I went to go pop my head
out my dad wasn't there and I was like
so crushed that he actually left and
then when I got at home got home that
day I was like dad you said you'd be
there and he was like well I'm gonna
have to get you in there somehow and
there was I'm not gonna stay there all
day I gotta I have to go to [ __ ] work
but it got easier
easier I guess right because I went back
and back him back I was such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know I really was such
a [ __ ] I remember when I was in
like preschool I remember you know how
like I like if I'm like you don't wear a
giant's hat you wear a forget a football
helmet like I genuinely think that it's
stupid to wear a [ __ ] not you I don't
think you're stupid for it but I think
it's like what are you doing if you get
a baseball hat with a football team on
it it's too confusing
so so I remember things like that from
my childhood like we had snack time at
[ __ ] mr. Pillsbury's which is the pre
school I went to pre-k and this little
girl was eating this wafer I think I
talked about this eating his wafer
eating her wafer with the tiniest bites
like tiniest [ __ ] bites and I was
looking at her as a preschool kid
getting getting pissed in my heart as a
kid that like sometimes missed the
toilet in my heart I was like I didn't
know the word I was it was I didn't know
the word like [ __ ] you know in my heart
like you know before I knew any better I
was like this [ __ ] chick [ __ ] is she
doing eatin with tiny you eatin with
normal bites dude and I couldn't I was
like overwhelmed as a kid and I looked
at her and told finally I cracked and it
was the first time I cracked now I'll do
it all day long I'll say hey why are you
doing that why are you doing this why
are you doing that ID is why I have this
podcast
thank God posture podcasts were invented
for that little child who got so much
[ __ ] feeling in his heart from that
little girl eating
little [ __ ] bites of a wafer I'll
never forget this and I said hey why are
you taking such little bites you should
take normal bites and she clap back not
[ __ ] and clap back she was like looked
at me like what do you mean and she
ended up saying she said and actually
now that I think about it's really cute
but she said if I take smaller bites
then it lasts longer and I remember as a
kid thinking nah nah you don't get as
much flavor with the small bites you
take regular bites and you experience it
the way you're supposed to experience it
and every bite you get as much flavor as
you possibly can
you know but she didn't have any of that
man she wanted those little bites man
she wanted a little bit of flavor for a
longer amount of time dude
that describes me man if I can fit that
[ __ ] whole thing in my mouth that's
where it's going man all of it
I want that much flavor in my [ __ ]
mouth if you made a wafer and it wasn't
big enough for me to enjoy it for long
enough you [ __ ] up way for a company
that [ __ ] is mine immediately now and
then gone I consumed bro but this little
girl
you know god bless her hopefully she's
still alive take a little bites out of
life right yeah man
but that's that
was the first time I felt like that as a
kid like you know what dude now no no no
no no no no no no you don't wear a
giant's hat you don't do that you were a
San Francisco Giants hat you were a
baseball Giants hat but you don't wear a
[ __ ] New York Giants baseball hat you
get the helmet and you [ __ ] go
shopping that's what you do yeah I
always I think about that too I wonder
what the
girls doing now that little girl I
wonder what she's doing it's probably
somewhere wearing a [ __ ] Bengals hat
wearing a [ __ ] she's probably
somewhere wearing a Jets hat just
somewhere at some coffee bean on some
other side of the country
she's 40 now you know she's 40 now just
enjoying her day just wearing an a an
Oilers baseball hat an Edmonton Oilers
hockey baseball hat eating a salad
somewhere uh that's good it's good to
think about I think it's good to think
about your childhood I think about my
childhood I had a great childhood though
so I guess if you had a bad childhood
it's probably not so good to think about
I remember one time I was uh I was so
mad at my brother or something or way no
oh wait no I was mad at my mom at
something she wouldn't let me do
something or something I was being a
[ __ ] brat and I was like [ __ ]
remember when running away was a threat
like I'm gonna run away I was like I'm
gonna run away mom
and she was like fine go and I went and
we had like this door before the outside
door we had well no it was like a four
yeah I guess and there was a door to the
foyer or and and and then and then the
door outside and I walked into the for
yay and I hid behind the side of the
foyer and my brother started crying
because he thought I ran away and my mom
and my mom and my dad my brother was
like he really did it he ran away and I
[ __ ] and my mom entered the foyer and
she was like you didn't run away you
[ __ ] and she grabbed me and she
was like get back in here you make him
[ __ ] brother cry dude how insane our
kids man you're supposed to grow up bro
I didn't grow up man I pull that petty
[ __ ] now I'll pretend to run away now do
I'll [ __ ] pretend to run away now man
if you don't like if you don't like it
dude I'll run away that's it man I can't
wait to get married I'll run away I'll
threaten my wife all day long I'm okay
I'll run away dude I worked so hard and
my you know you know if I have a like a
housewife is a sexist but if I was like
a dude I worked so hard all I wanted is
dinner to be ready on the table and it
wasn't ah but that's it I'm out I'm
running away and then just hide in the
foyer and then she comes back he didn't
run away here's your [ __ ] Turkey
idiot um this guy you know I realized
member I was asking you guys should i do
guests or not I didn't really want your
[ __ ] opinion but when I but uh uh I
some guy came up to me once at the end
of one of my shows in somewhere and he
was like you know what dude I really
liked your podcast but I think that it
might be cool if you did do gasps I
think you should and then I was thinking
ah and then I thought about it more and
I was like that guys have [ __ ] if
that guy's and in I think that guy is
like not that smart because here's the
deal you do realize if I if I had guests
on my podcasts it would be a completely
different [ __ ] podcast I wouldn't be
able to do some of the bits that I do
and you know the stream-of-consciousness
thing would be gone and I think some of
you tune in for that [ __ ] but it'd be
gone
I'd have to interview some guy who wrote
a book or some [ __ ] and we'd be talking
about [ __ ] you know pelicans and I
then I'd start to be like you know what
pelicans are [ __ ] up because they got
that long beak but they don't need it
that long and they got a [ __ ] thing
and it's like when they're walk and they
should be flying and I'm saying all my
[ __ ] and then some boring ass
[ __ ] who wrote the book about
pelicans will be like well you know the
interesting thing about pelicans is that
are actually not monogamous even though
everyone thinks about it and then I
gotta listen to this guy [ __ ] talk
about some boring [ __ ] dude if you think
I should have guests from this podcast
what I want you to do
is I want you to turn around dude that's
what I want you to do turn around
that's the soundboard dude turn around
you think I should have guests gunk dude
guess what I'm Chris D'Elia
I'll never have guests then nice dude oh
nice you know I could have guessed if I
wanted to because it's free conch but
see ya yeah dude we're doing the sound
dude this is awesome man we're just
having the soundboard is soundboard es
day of all time dude [ __ ] yeah us
creating the soundboard man a picture of
us just on the [ __ ] computer making
it nice and then we're [ __ ] another
cut to us [ __ ] drawing a thing a mock
thing of the soundboard and then us
looking at it on a whiteboard and then
cutting ties jogging for no reason and
then cutting back to us on the computer
and then it cut to a [ __ ] printed out
blueprint of us having the [ __ ]
soundboard and then a cut I cut the
house a plane on the computer and we're
so [ __ ] happy dude and then it cuts
at us [ __ ] and then it stops and then
we go well here's the moment of truth
you think it'll work
I don't know click it and then and then
it plays all over again and it's a loop
like Inception do it [ __ ] yeah dude
soundboard look that's right dude
Oh
that's right dude that's right dude
North Carolina in the South Carolina
South Carolina and in North Carolina
sip sip sippin Mississippi ain't
Carolina sit there in Florida [ __ ]
rap songs always calling out [ __ ]
areas dude
remember that Huey Lewis song that did
it rock and roll rock and roll is in New
York San Francisco Chicago the [ __ ]
Vancouver in the man Texas Dallas and
Houston don't forget about I said
rock and roll you [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
just trying to appeal to everybody dude
you're like the [ __ ] black guy who
wears the jacket with all the NBA teams
on it you just like you don't even have
a team the [ __ ] out of here how about
that dude one time I saw a guy who wore
the the [ __ ] jacket with all the NBA
teams on it and then he had a [ __ ]
Orlando Magic baseball hat on what so is
that your favorite look I was looking so
desperately for the early I was like did
they leave out to learn the magic on the
jacket or something
there's probably there I couldn't find
it but man it was so funny
black guys aware that [ __ ] jacket
till they die bro dad that they loved
that jacket with all the NBA teams on it
with all the logos on it bro that's so
funny man that deal with my dude they'll
wear that and and you know what Mexicans
wear a baseball hat and they don't give
a [ __ ] what is on it I never seen a race
wear a [ __ ] wear something that they
don't care what's on it more than
Mexican guys they will wear a [ __ ]
Charlotte Hornets baseball hat and you'd
be like oh you like the Charlotte
Hornets and the literally beat they
literally say what and you'd be like the
Charlotte Hornets hat huh
you got it Charla Hornung you Charlotte
Ron it's a fan and they'll go oh ho ho
that's the [ __ ] white guy version of
the [ __ ] carnation Rose shorts I'm
saying what are you looking at that guy
what is that just the the picture of it
what's his name that guy Junior
dude when that guy how could you [ __ ] up
that bad when he did that thing I've got
a picture here at Junior Smith wearing a
basketball jersey with all the logos on
it is that real or is that Photoshop
it's gotta be Photoshop right okay how
and it's got the supreme thing on it
I was watching the thing about two toys
that made us on Netflix where's that
medicine Netflix and I was watching the
Hello Kitty episode dude what the [ __ ]
is Hello Kitty man it's unbelievable
it's so popular it's worth like 5
billion dollars and it's basically
supreme they literally put a Hello Kitty
on anything and and that's it yeah how
much is it $400 new NBA basketball
hardwood classics Hamilton new NBA
hardwood classics Hamilton leather all
teams patch jacket selling on eBay you
you're wondering if they have your size
well this one is a seven extra large how
[ __ ] American is that that first of
all they have all the basketball teams
nothing more American maybe baseball
than basketball with all the teams
because you can't make up your mind cuz
you're a [ __ ] and it's fatter than
[ __ ]
the only time you could buy that is if
you're on my 600 pound life and then
you'd be like I can't wait to [ __ ]
get my tummy tuck or I can't wait to get
my stomach
so I can get that so I don't have to
wear that jacket anymore I could get a
regular Hornets jacket seven extra-large
what are you floating up what is it a
[ __ ] what are gonna get married in it
somebody's holding your train on the bat
and the back
that's so [ __ ] there's nothing more
rich [ __ ] you than uh having having a
[ __ ] what's it say original price was
$1,600 whoo
material lambskin leather condition new
gender men I mean gender giant team NBA
all team patch jacket colors
multicolored I mean you could see that
your to read it
Wow says extra-large dude in case you
have nine shoulders oh my god seven
extra-large
oh [ __ ] yeah but there's nothing more
rich [ __ ] you than having a wedding
first of all and then having a train on
your wedding dress and then having
[ __ ] people carry it behind you man
all right we're gonna wrap this up dude
the third leg of
fourth flag of the tours up or whatever
now third leg is the tours up now fourth
leg of the tour third leg of the tour
Ottawa London Ontario Buffalo Burlington
Philadelphia Washington New York I'm
since a the state's New Jersey Oregon
Washington BC
Vancouver Florida's some of the things
in Florida's Georgia some of the ones in
Los Angeles San Francisco Boston
Massachusetts California Fresno other
ones in Bakersfield Austin this is the
follow-the-leader torque who's coming to
San Antonio get your tickets now dude we
got Delaware coming up in this week
Delaware coming up this week
Mashantucket Connecticut change it and
that's about it dude Las Vegas Reno
Portland Maine Hampton Beach New
Hampshire Tulsa Oklahoma Midwest City
Oklahoma
follow the leader tour is coming so
subscribe to our YouTube so square cash
check out the new booster rewards
program get the cash app and two rewards
code Congrats get $5 give $5 - times up
get it for iOS or Android now subscribe
to the YouTube channel please every new
video has every new video every every
new every week Tuesday or Wednesday
would come out with a new video so
subscribe to the YouTube channel and we
got something excited exciting here we
got a hundred thousand subscribers and
on the video podcast you'll be able to
see me hold this up this is our plaque
for the 100,000 subscribers so thank you
YouTube with a nice little letter they
sent it to us and I think we already out
like almost 140 subscribers so do it I
don't mean to be like this but
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] for a 2-foot Akon coming out
with little baby convict jeans on down
so download the Chris D'Elia app for iOS
or Android now and you can be with me
live when I shoot the when I shoot the
podcast and do the podcast which is
sometimes a day or two before
yeah a day or two before yeah or a day
before at least subscribe rate and
review the show it really helps if
you're a baby and if you're a part of
this cult you've got to do that you've
got to do all these things because it
helps us grow and we got to kick it into
high gear we've got to kick it into high
gear it's not like the end of days are
coming because this cult isn't about the
end of days this cult is about living
that hedonistic lifestyle so that's it
thanks for listening guys and remember
dude
[Music]